tenemos un problema muy interesante esta
es una copa de cristal en forma de cono
invertido cuya altura es de 4
centímetros y cuyo diámetro en la parte
superior es también de 4 centímetros
estoy vertiendo agua a razón de un
centímetro cúbico por segundo un
centímetro cúbico por segundo y el agua
en este momento se encuentra a una
altura de 2 centímetros la altura que
hay desde el fondo de la copa hasta este
punto esta altura es de 2 centímetros y
la pregunta es bueno sabemos que el
volumen al cual se está advirtiendo el
agua es un centímetro cúbico por segundo
y en el momento en que la altura del
agua es de 2 centímetros y se está
vertiendo el agua a un centímetro cúbico
por segundo
queremos saber cuando la altura del agua
es de 2 centímetros queremos saber a qué
razón está cambiando la altura del agua
a qué razón está cambiando la altura del
agua a qué razón esta altura está
cambiando
sabemos que está a dos centímetros pero
queremos saber a qué razón está
cambiando bien analicemos el problema
nos han dado la razón a la cual el
volumen del agua está cambiando
pongámoslo por acá nos han dado la razón
a la cual el volumen está cambiando con
respecto al tiempo y la razón a la cual
está cambiando este volumen es un
centímetro cúbico por segundo y que nos
están preguntando nos están preguntando
la razón a la cual esta altura h cambia
en el momento en que la altura del agua
es de dos centímetros
anotemos esto por acá nos están
preguntando la razón a la que cambia la
altura h con respecto al tiempo de h en
de t si contestamos esto habremos
resuelto el problema para esto
necesitamos encontrar una relación que
sea válida para todo tiempo entre el
volumen y la altura la cual vamos a
derivar probablemente usando la regla de
la cadena para a partir de ahí obtener
una relación entre la razón a la que
cambia el volumen y la razón a la que
cambia la altura
hagamos esto paso a paso primero
obtengamos unas relaciones del volumen y
la altura bueno de hecho es algo que ya
nos dieron acá la fórmula que nos dan
aquí la tenemos es que el volumen del
cono es igual a un tercio del área de la
base del cono por la altura del cono no
la vamos a demostrar aquí quizás en un
curso de cálculo integral donde veamos
sólidos de revolución lo haremos por lo
pronto vamos a tomar como válido que
esta es la manera de calcular el volumen
del cono bien dado esto podemos obtener
una expresión que nos relacione el
volumen con la altura del cuerpo del
agua aquí vamos a ponerlo a poner en
azul vamos a ponerlo en azul porque
estamos calculando el volumen del cuerpo
del agua así es que el volumen va a ser
igual
un tercio del área de la superficie del
agua un tercio de área
superficie
de agua por la altura del agua por
h como calculamos el área la superficie
del agua bien nos damos cuenta de que
aquí en la parte superior de la copa el
diámetro es de 4 centímetros y la altura
también es de 4 centímetros y esta
relación entre diámetro y altura se va a
conservar aquí en el cuerpo cónico de
agua aquí vamos a tener la misma
relación entre diámetro y altura pues
estas de aquí son dos líneas rectas así
que en cualquier momento dado la
relación entre esto y esto se va a
preservar por lo que el diámetro aquí en
la superficie del agua va a ser igual a
la altura h a partir de esto podemos
calcular que el radio es igual a h sobre
2 por lo que aquí el área de la
superficie del agua va a ser igual a pi
por radio al cuadrado
h sobre 2 al cuadrado
eso es el área la superficie de agua por
supuesto esto multiplicado por un tercio
y multiplicado también por h vamos a
simplificar esta expresión esto es igual
a
montes yo por ti por h al cuadrado sobre
4 por h y esto que es igual bien en el
numerador tenemos y por h cúbica todo
eso dividido entre 12 así que esto es el
volumen ahora lo que necesitamos
calcular es qué tan rápido cambia el
volumen con respecto al tiempo y qué tan
rápido cambia la altura con respecto al
tiempo y dado que nos interesa el cambio
de ambas con respecto al tiempo pues
vamos a tomar la derivada con respecto
al tiempo a ambos lados de esta
expresión hagamos eso necesito primero
mover esto un poco a la derecha
ligeramente a la derecha
ahí lo tenemos
y ahora sí voy a tomar la derivada con
respecto al tiempo a ambos lados
entonces del lado izquierdo que tenemos
la derivada con respecto al tiempo del
volumen b y del lado derecho de la ayuda
con respecto al tiempo de esta expresión
del lado izquierdo la deriva con
respecto al tiempo del volumen b es
simplemente deben de t debe en de t lo
cual es igual a la derivada con respecto
al t de esta expresión sacamos las
constantes y sobre 12 que multiplica que
multiplica a la derivada con respecto a
t de h h al cubo para que quede claro lo
que vamos a hacer vamos a suponer que h
depende del tiempo de hecho
efectivamente depende del tiempo a
medida que pasa el tiempo estamos
vertiendo agua sobre la copa por lo cual
esta altura va aumentando ok para que
quede claro lo que vamos a hacer
entonces voy a poner esto de la forma h
h como función de te voy a ponerlo en
otro color h
dt elevado al cubo y como calculamos la
derivada con respecto a t dht elevado al
cubo estoy seguro que en este momento te
está sonando en la cabeza la famosísima
regla de la cadena vamos a reescribir
todo por acá abajo tenemos que debe de t
es igual vamos a ponerlo en el color
adecuado es igual a pi sobre 12 por la
derivada con respecto a t de hdt al cubo
ahora como derivamos esto bueno aquí
tenemos algo elevado al cubo la real de
la cadena establece que primero hay que
derivar algo elevado al cubo con
respecto a ese algo y eso va a ser
dejando escribir esto de nueva cuenta en
un color distinto eso va a ser igual a 3
por htc
elevado al cuadrado por la derivada de
ese algo con respecto a t en este caso
sería por th y av cs rosa
x
dh en dt para que quede claro como
estamos usando la regla y la cadena que
tenemos aquí
aquí estamos sacando la derivada de hdt
al cubo con respecto a hdt
y eso lo estamos multiplicando por la
derivada de hdt con respecto a t estamos
encontrando así la derivada de hdt al
cubo con respecto a p es decir esto es
igual a
la derivada de hdt al cubo con respecto
qué es exactamente lo que queremos
calcular qué tan rápido está cambiando
con respecto al tiempo esta expresión
hdt al cubo vamos entonces a reescribir
esto para que quede más claro lo voy a
hacer por acá arriba la razón a la que
está cambiando la razón a la que está
cambiando el volumen con respecto al
tiempo esto va a ser igual
y sobre 12 x 3 x hdt al cuadrado que lo
voy a escribir simplemente como 3 h
cuadrada x por la razón a la que cambia
la altura con respecto al tiempo la
derivada de h con respecto al tiempo por
de h
en dt y aquí podría haber algo de
confusión a la mejor podrías haber
intentado aquí tomar la derivada de esto
con respecto a h pero recuerda estamos
tratando de ver cómo están cambiando las
cosas con respecto al tiempo y aunque
expresamos el volumen con una función de
la altura pero dado que h también es una
función del tiempo estamos derivando
ambos lados con respecto al tiempo es
por eso que estamos usando la regla de
la cadena para derivar hdt con respecto
al tiempo estamos suponiendo que h es
una función del tiempo ahora bien a
dónde nos lleva esta expresión bueno nos
han dado cuando se estableció el
problema cuanto vale de vendée t
aquí nos lo dieron de venderte es igual
a un centímetro cúbico por segundo
así es que conocemos que deben de t es
igual a un centímetro cúbico
también conocemos la altura la altura en
este momento específico que es igual a
dos centímetros conocemos entonces que
la altura es igual a dos centímetros la
única incógnita que tenemos es la razón
a la que cambia la altura con respecto
al tiempo él lo que nos están
preguntando es de un principio de hdt
hagamos eso por acá abajo tenemos uno
deja de poner el mismo color tenemos que
un centímetro cúbico por segundo nueva
pone unidades para ahorrar espacio esto
va a ser igual a y medios déjame
describirlo con el color adecuado y
medios
y esto multiplicado por tres por la
altura al cuadrado tres por dos al
cuadrado que es igual a 4 3 por 4 espera
creo que tenemos un error aquí sí aquí
aquí tenemos un error esto es pido si a
vos y esto es pido seamos perfecto
entonces tenemos videos ya dos por tres
por la altura al cuadrado que es igual a
cuatro y esto multiplicado por dh en dt
y todo esto igual a uno que tenemos
entonces que uno es igual 3 por 4 2 es
simplifica con este 12 1 es igual a pi
por dh en dt despejamos de hdt
dividiendo entre de ambos lados y que
obtenemos tenemos nuestro gran final
tenemos que la tasa la cual aumenta la
profundidad con respecto al tiempo
cuando estamos vertiendo un centímetro
cúbico por segundo de agua y en el
momento en que dicha profundidad es de 2
centímetros va a ser igual a 1 sobre pi
no hemos hecho el análisis dimensional
perestelo puede ser por tu cuenta esto
va a ser uno sobre pi centímetros
por segundo puedes hacer el análisis
dimensional si lo deseas incluyendo las
dimensiones aquí y él o aquí esto indica
que tan rápido está creciendo la altura
exactamente en ese momento